breaking news out of chicago ashawn just
said according to police 14 people were
injured most of them shot near a funeral
home
and a community called auburn gresham
now at a presser just a short time ago
police said
there was some kind of planned ambush
outside the funeral home
where a memorial service was going on
inside for a homicide victim
at the end of last week in chicago
murders were up 51 percent
shootings were up 44 percent 47 percent
actually and despite those staggering
numbers
mayor lori lightfoot has presided over a
city
that has turned into the wild west now
let me make this as clear as i can make
it tonight
it's open season on the citizens of
chicago
and the mayor cannot be bothered to
accept
real federal help you know why because
of her seething hatred
for donald trump that is outweighing her
concern
for the citizens that she is supposed to
be serving
now the head of the chicago fraternal
order of police was here tonight to
react to mayor lori lightfoot's refusal
to accept federal help
but will instead react to this story
john canazera joins me now exclusively
john
are you as unhinged
as mayor lightfoot says you are see
she's putting it on you
mr canazera that's what she's doing
putting it on you
and maybe it's it's fox or it's trump or
everyone
but looking in the mirror and also going
after the criminals
well good evening laura thanks for
having me first of all you know
the mayor likes to use the word unhinged
the ironic part is that
the mayor became unhinged i could i wish
i could show you the text messages
that she sent me over the weekend as
soon as she found out that i had sent
the request to president trump
i mean she was the one who became
totally unhinged unprofessional
childish it was really pathetic for a
leader of a city
well right now we have carnage as far as
the eye can see
we don't know what will happen we
certainly hope we don't have
deaths out of these uh injuries but it
looked pretty wild out there in the
scene that they were showing
this is outside of a funeral home so if
you're going to
shoot outside of a funeral home where
there was some signage about the funeral
they had on
the street apparently there was some
police presence
somewhere on the scene you're you've
gotten really bold haven't you john that
you're you're pretty bold at that point
as a criminal
you're not worried well you know like
sean's guest just said
there the bold is there because they
know there's no consequences the justice
system in cook county
is totally broken all the way from the
president precwinkle
to kim fox the prosecutor to tom dart
the sheriff to tim evans the chief judge
they have no idea what real justice is
and that's basically
the bloodbath in the street is the
result well lori lightfoot just to bring
people into this
uh back and forth to put it politely
john
between you and lightfoot this is what
she said everyone watch
we've got it we've got an unhinged
leader of the fraternal order of police
who is craving and trying to get
generate attention
this is a dangerous road for us to go
down we're not going to have people
that don't know our streets engaging in
clearly
unconstitutional conduct
operating at will in our city that is
chaos
that is lawlessness that's chaos
what we're seeing tonight wasn't chaos
but you were wanting federal help
and actual assistance as chaos this
woman doesn't know her own city
okay it's a travesty i am i thought i
was mad about other things tonight given
what's going on in this country
but this is an outrage is a great
american city it's being disserved by
her she's a radical
they need to toss her out of office john
go ahead
she's she's literally running the
titanic into an iceberg intentionally
56 rounds fired i'm told and 17 people
shot tonight at a funeral where there
was police
obviously special attention because of
the gang
victim that was already being waked at
the funeral home
you know the irony about her not knowing
the city streets and the federal
officers
she just and this isn't a knock on
superintendent brown because i really
like superintendent brown
but she just hired an outsider who
didn't know the city who didn't know the
streets
so what's the difference again she's a
big hypocrite
she has a bit of a napoleon complex if
you don't agree with her heaven forbid
well funeral attendees i understand
returned fire on the on the vehicle
so these were all gang bangers right i
mean this is if you had to like just sum
it up and for us i mean
the conjecture at this point we need to
know more but people are firing on each
other
i mean we called it the wild west this
is a killing field in chicago
and we're complaining about trump are
you kidding me
talk about blame shifting putting it on
on you
in the fraternal order of police or the
cops on the beat
what what the heck are the cops supposed
to do when they have no support from
city hall
what are they supposed to do you
highlighted the the obviously increase
in
shootings and murders but you know
superintendent brown
basically said yesterday that the police
department has uh recovered 5400 guns
so far this year off the streets of
chicago now as he's
as he properly highlighted that's 54
deadly encounter 5 400 deadly encounters
that the men and women of the police
department have you know dealt with over
the
first six months of this year and not a
single person
well i shouldn't say not a single person
i think there's only been three
shootings
uh that resulted in death but my point
is
how many more guns or how many more
murders would occur if those guns
weren't taken off the street
and more importantly there's a lot of
people that were arrested with those
guns
that were immediately let back out on
the street again and it goes right back
to kim fox and the broken county jail
system
this is the revolving door of of
so-called criminal justice reform
someone's arrested on a monday they're
released on tuesday morning
they get their criminal defender their
public defender
and and we're crying about how unfair
the system is
and i i just wanna and if everyone's
just joining us tonight there was a
disturbing scene in chicago
a few hours ago at a funeral where we
had 14 people shot
many in the hospital people were
returning fire
from the funeral to the the cars that
were
going off in different directions
apparently that were responsible for the
shootings
coming from multiple directions the
reports we're getting tonight
john and at the same time as this is
happening tonight
we have utter lawlessness in another
great american city
of portland oregon and we have people in
portland oregon who are telling the
media
not to cover it because that tells a
very distorted story and people are
covering it
because they want to they they want to
hurt people politically no
we want to cover it because we want to
save lives property and livelihoods
what will happen if aoc and the gang
get their way with biden and the whole
crowd and defund the police because
this is defund and dismantle the police
movements across this country john is
tonight's scene going to be repeated
across urban america
well about urban america but you know
chicago is pretty unique to anywhere
else in the country
i've said it time and time again that
we're approximately
new york is two and a half times the
size population wise to chicago but we
have 40 percent more murders
than the whole city of new york just let
that sink in i mean there is a mindless
uh lawless mindness set in this city
where you know they just do whatever
they want
because there is no repercussion there
is no accountability this is
piggybacking
on friday night's scene where there was
a large group of officers
trying to protect a christopher columbus
statue that was being attempted to be
pulled down
52 officers were injured in that melee
and they want to pretend like this was
just a handful of anarchists that
embedded themselves in this protest
the protesters knew that this was going
to happen they protected these people
until they went down
and we talk about accountability lastly
just this point so accountability you
know they cry that
police officers don't speak out the thin
blue line they protect bad behavior
what about all those good protesters who
stood there and watched these anarchists
her hurl fireworks frozen water bricks
at officers and did nothing they did
nothing
i'm tired of the of the of the line that
they're all the good protesters
you shouldn't be out throwing stuff at
police or standing by other people who
are throwing stuff at police okay
shouldn't be pulling down statues
they're not your property if you want to
take down a statue
go the legal way and petition your local
aldermen and do it that way don't put
ropes around statues and pull them down
okay that's just that's thuggish
behavior
and we're tolerating it in chicago and
all across this country it's a broken
windows theory it's a broken statues
theory okay